with the fall surge in cases of coid and
respiratory illnesses more
hospitalization uh there are a certain
number of deaths that are occurring it's
back to wearing masks fulltime at all
healthc care settings with back to
school the started three weeks ago I
think inevitably there's exchange of
viruses and that includes coid Global
News has obtained a memo from the
Ministry of Health to healthc care
providers in preparation for the viral
respiratory illness this fall and winter
BC will be reinstating enhanced
infection prevention and control
measures in healthc care settings
services and programs including
Community physician offices and
outpatient
clinics The Province set to make the
announcement Thursday but it's not a
secret we've been talking about this for
about a month that uh for the
respiratory illness season in the fall
we we would expect in healthcare
settings enhanced masking the measures
set to go into effect next Tuesday will
include continuous masking by all
healthcare workers patients and visitors
long-term care settings though are not
included in the renewed directive there
is concern of push back the move
contentious for some I want to believe
people recognize that the patients who
are in those facilities are vulnerable
and although will understand why they
have to do it will still do it and not
cause too much grief or physical
violence meanwhile Healthcare officials
urging the public to get the flu and Co
19 shots hoping it reduces cases enough
to reverse the masking requirement
although some health experts would like
to see a stronger directive for masks to
become not mandatory and I really would
like us all to go towards mask guidance
mask edette but strongly recommended
year round KL kurali Global News